so we're given the following equation
that 5 times the absolute value of x
plus 3 minus 3 is equal to 7 it's always
a little daunting to see an equation
with an absolute value sign when you
only have one of them like this what I
like to do is isolate it and just kind
of think it through from that point so
let's try to isolate the absolute value
of x plus 3 here let's try to isolate
that part of our equation so the first
thing we might want to do is add 3 to
both sides of the equation that will get
rid of this minus 3 or this negative 3
on the left-hand side so let's add 3 to
both sides of this equation and this
will turn the equation in to do it in
that same pink color the left-hand side
will still it'll be 5 times the absolute
value of x plus 3 the minus 3 or the
negative 3 plus the 3 those will cancel
out that'll just be 0 and then that will
be equal to 7 plus 3 which is 10 now we
have 5 times the thing we want to
isolate the best way to isolate it
completely is to divide both sides of
this equation by 5 so if you divide that
side by 5 and then the right-hand side
by 5 we divided by 5 so that these guys
will cancel out 5 times something
divided by 5 is just that something so
these cancel out that's 2 so we're left
with the absolute value of x plus 3 is
equal to 10 divided by 5 which is 2 so
we've simplified the equation a good but
now we just have to put our our thinking
caps on a little bit if the absolute
value of something is 2 what does it
mean that that something is what are the
two numbers that if I were to take its
absolute value I could get 2 we know
I'll do a little thing on the side here
we know that the absolute value of 2 is
equal to 2 so maybe this thing will is
equal to 2 so maybe X plus 3 is equal to
2 if X plus 3 is equal to 2 then you
take its absolute value you're going to
get 2 again but we also know we also
know that the absolute value of negative
2 is
also equal to two so maybe X plus three
is equal to negative two because if X
plus three is equal to negative two and
we take its absolute value then we're
gonna get two again so we could also
write or X plus three could be equal to
negative two that's what I mean about
thinking out thinking about a little bit
another way to think about it I've said
this in other videos is absolute value
means distance from zero so if we were
to draw a number line here if we were to
draw a number line here that is zero
this is saying that whatever this
quantity is inside the absolute value
sign its distance from zero is two so
what numbers are two away from zero well
you have positive two you I'll write a
positive there explicitly and you also
have a negative two so this thing here
could be a positive two or it could be a
negative two
either way you take the absolute value
of a positive 2 or a negative 2
you're going to get a two so let's solve
these so over here we can subtract 3
from both sides of this equation so if
you subtract 3 from both sides you get
the left-hand side you're just left with
an X these threes cancel out that's the
whole point of subtracting the 3 X will
be equal to 2 minus 3 is negative 1 so
that is one solution to our absolute
value equation and what's our other
solution well here once again let's
subtract 3 from both sides so you
subtract 3 from both sides the left-hand
side just becomes an X the right-hand
side negative 2 minus 3 is negative 5 so
this is our other our other solution
let's verify that they both work so if X
is equal to negative 1 what is this
expression because what does this
equation become we have 5 times the
absolute value of negative 1 plus 3
minus 3 and if this really is a solution
then this should be equal to negative 2
positive 7 let's see this is 5 times
negative 1 plus 3 is is
- so it's five times the absolute value
of two - three the absolute value of 2
is just 2 so this is 5 times 2 - 3 5
times 2 is 10 minus 3 which is indeed
equal to 7 so this is definitely a
solution let's try the other one out X
is equal to negative 5 running out of
some real estate but I can clear some up
right here if X is equal to negative 5
same drill 5 times the absolute value of
negative 5 negative 5 plus 3 minus 3
this again should be equal to 7
negative 5 plus 3 is negative 2 so this
is 5 times the absolute value of
negative 2 minus 3 the absolute value of
negative 2 is positive 2 so this is 5
times 2 minus 3 which is 10 minus 3 10
minus 3 which is again equal to 7 and
notice in this situation the thing in
the absolute value sign became a
negative 2 because we said oh X plus 3
could be equal to negative 2 in the
magenta situation the thing in the
absolute value sign was positive 2
because this was the situation where we
assumed that the thing in the absolute
value sign was a positive 2 now if we
were to graph these solutions on the
number line if we were to graph the two
solutions on a number line I'll draw a
new number line here let me draw a new
number line just like that both of these
are less than 0 so I'll put 0 all the
way over here maybe 0 1 2 let's go to
negative negative 1 negative 2 negative
3 negative 4 negative 5 negative 6
this solution right here X is equal to
negative 1 we could plot on the number
line it's right over there and then the
other solution X is equal to negative 5
we can plot it right over there
hopefully you found that enjoyable